the rocks in a disaster movie with a lot
of earthquakes what this is why I have a
theory that every time the rock flexes
the fault line just goes down and now
we're here because it's happened again
san andreas so san andreas is a disaster
movie starring everyone's favorite
wedding officiant the San Andreas Fault
is finally doing what Lex Luthor was
trying to make it do in the first
Superman movie little did he know he had
to wait 37 years and do it naturally and
he could have just saved himself the
cost of a nukes all this shit's
happening in California's trying to make
Otisville and now the rock needs to get
to his daughter the father trying to get
to his kid and the family's trying to
unite among a huge disasters don't think
about it this movie is a more
interesting version of The Day After
Tomorrow with less snow and more
earthquakes create a movie like this you
want the effects to look good that's
what's gonna pull you into it you're
like host it's like it's really
happening the first thing that happens
in this movie this car goes over a
precipice and it's just flipping up and
over itself and I was like well that
looks terrible hopefully it doesn't all
look like that some does some effects
actually look really good it's like a
mix it's like the special effects we're
done by two different people in this
movie I'm gonna get to what I like about
it first of all I love the rock cuz it's
just he's good he's like a likable guy
as that sunny smiling you're like you
know what you're the biggest beefiest
awesome kid ever go save the day dad
rest of the movie is pretty generic in
this movie is pretty much like the
earthquakes are going up the San Andreas
Fault and they're just getting worse and
worse and worse every time why well
because we need to movie called San
Andreas dude don't think about it
doesn't just roll with it the script the
lines in this movie holy looks it's
once a Paul Giamatti learns that this
stuff is going to happen someone's like
who should we call he's like everybody
it's exactly what I would think a movie
like this would have we just not
prepared for the cheesiness when it's
delivered and what this movie suffers
from is ultimately what Day After
Tomorrow did suffer from also and 2012
and even Independence Day is that it
tries to concentrate on character after
the really cool shits happen so you have
this downswing this downtime we were
like oh it's kind of boring now and you
need character development especially in
a movie like this if you're gonna care
about the characters what is such a hard
balance to find among a movie that's
just about destroying to then go oh
hey here's some well-written stuff for
the characters yeah this is so you care
later on
one disaster movie in recent memory that
I can think of that did it well that's
Titanic Titanic is totally a disaster
movie for you naysayers out there and I
think it's a good movie for you other
naysayers out there seriously that's it
that's just kind of a byproduct of a
disaster movies that most all of them
have that downswing where it's like yes
you know how to write disaster you just
don't know how to write good character
development and some consistency would
be great too there's just one thing you
saw the scene in the trailer with this
huge tsunami and it was just it was
awesome not in that awesome kind of way
but it was just so big and intimidating
and scary I was like that's well done
and it's just destroying a bunch of
stuff and that our main characters have
to deal with it and it just after seeing
everything get wiped out in the impact
of this way where it was like Oh God
hold on and I and it's just like ah
that's a really inconvenient wave of
water is hold on we'll get through it I
was like well you guys should be dead
cuz in the in San Andreas had a lot of
what I was going into the movie for but
it did suffer from what I'm probably
gonna end up calling from now on
disaster movie itis these people know
how to make great destruction on screen
but then they try to make the movie a
little deeper and have deeper characters
and it just ends up blown up in their
face because they don't know how to do
it make no mistake it has a lot of fun
in it if you want to just watch a
disaster movie and you're like that's
why I'm there I don't care you're gonna
have a lot of fun with this movie for
sure hell I had a lot of fun with this
movie this is probably gonna be proof
that not all movies that get this
writing are actually bad or no negatives
there are no positives there are just
the opinions because San Andreas is
definitely a good time if you're drunk
yeah now is a party the room spinning
good is a party alright guys so your
favorite disaster movie of all time what
is it
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more